o o
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
owen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les fans 12 ouais c'est un [ __ ] c'est
générer un patrie [ __ ] c'est génial ça
lui je suis sûr qu'on se connaît patrick
je suis lucas lui cabaret je suis
président du comité officiel de l'humour
sont rares en sort h libre libertin et
puis merde la cool quoi un coup à jouer
nous excusez nous on est en plein de
services à l'étape sont dressés et à
pâte l'étape si oui est ce que je fais
alors bon cyril vasil ce soir son aval à
tout maintien soit un grand monsieur
monsieur patrick sébastien calvet calmos
gérer envie de déconner quercia
si je suis là ce soir c'est parce que le
taulier est en danger à français on
essaie de te musée mon patrick la vie
tout à l'heure alors je profite de ta
présence pour importer dire que t'es pas
tout seul tout le comité derrière toi tu
as les couilles au cul mon pote on est
tous là et je peux dire qu on va
papillon va pas faire le dos rond parce
que sinon qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
on va se faire ah c'est pas moi qui
l'ait dit ah les hommes qui regardent
hockey merde alors alors la patronne de
français delphine ernotte elle est
géniale
elle a fait disparaître six numéros de
cabaret en une saison est renoncer
c'est la belle hilary lui ces risques
est d'ailleurs dans service public
akwaya service eia
j'étais et estival public il veut qu'on
lui en mettre plein la gueule je parlais
pas et bien sûr attention féerie en
batteries dans les années bonheur
d'alzheimer tu recevais toto cutugno et
l'une le chrtr et riche et le tort à
20h30 sur france 2 ça a quand même une
autre gueule que stéphane bern petit
film du caillou avec un drone [ __ ] pas
vraiment patrick battut fait rêver les
gens tels êtres gims aussi impopulaire
mais bien sûr tu es populaire mais
apparemment dans ce pays
populaire c'est un grand mot je suis pas
d'accord pierre c'est pas un gros mot
beats à chalon alors alors à quelques
pas du comité on a une idée j'aime faire
la tronche je m'habille et un raté
l'épreuve pour toi français les me dire
mon pote que la couille et vague
attendant écoute un peu l'hymne cantat à
composer à crc une bricole ça s'appelle
le vire pas
[Applaudissements]
l'adjani aurait assez de mots comme ça
ça me permet hélas
[Musique]
pour l'atrix est ce qu'on espère bien
pas venir
avant les artistes populaires ne vient
pas
jacques higelin l'univers enchanté
cookie dingler
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors là le reconnais que je pense que
ça va secouer 13 avr 11 avril je suis
quoi vos patrick l'après midi il fera
bon presque un peu par foule c'est
génial et fera 17 at il dit c'est ta
maison du val d'oise et demain nous
fêteront la saint jean
pour moi tu le seigneur hercule c el
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aqsa 3ème boulot à des effectifs et la
chanson franchement c'est très fort le
bertrand huawei